(man) TONIGHT MARK CUBAN
JOINS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
COME SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS,
FIVE POWERFUL, SELF‐MADE
INVESTORS WORTH BILLIONS.
IN THE TANK,
THE SHARKS ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT BUSINESS.
WHICH ONE OF YOU SHARKS IS
READY TO INVEST IN US?
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
I'M GONNA GO BACK IN.
BARBARA.
ROBERT'S GIVING ME THE EYE
THAT IT'S A LOAN.
ROBERT GIVES YOU THE EYE,
BUT HE DOESN'T GIVE ANY MONEY.
BUT FIRST THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
IF I COULD EXPLAIN TO YOU GUYS
A LITTLE CLEARER‐‐
NO, JAMES,
YOU GOTTA STOP SELLING.
I COULD NOT SPEAK TO YOU.
YOU TOOK FOREVER.
(laughs)
BOOM GOES THE DYNAMITE!
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
HE STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH HE EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN‐‐
THIS FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO A REAL ESTATE EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
IN THE SHARK‐FILLED CITY
OF MANHATTAN.
DAYMOND JOHN
TURNED RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION
IN WORLDWIDE RETAIL SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC,
THE SON OF A FACTORY WORKER
TURNED TECHNOLOGY MOGUL,
SOLD HIS FIRST
INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
AND MARK CUBAN‐‐
THIS SELF‐MADE BILLIONAIRE
STARTED OUT AS A PAPERBOY,
AND NOW IS A MEDIA MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
♪♪♪
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK IS
JONATHAN BOOS
WITH AN INNOVATIVE PRODUCT LINE
FOR THE WELL‐DRESSED MAN.
HI, EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN BOOS,
AND I'M THE OWNER OF
THE MEN'S BRAND WURKIN STIFFS,
AS WELL AS THE INVENTOR
OF POWER STAYS,
THE WORLD'S ONLY
MAGNETIC COLLAR STAYS.
I'M SEEKING $85,000
FOR 10% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
NOW THIS ALL STARTED BACK
WHEN I WAS ACTUALLY RUNNING LATE
FOR SOME DINNER RESERVATIONS.
MY WIFE WAS YELLING AS SHE THREW
A BRAND‐NEW SHIRT AT ME
TO PUT ON, AND I'D SEEN
THAT I HAD A‐A BIG PROBLEM.
I LOOKED LIKE JOHN TRAVOLTA
FROM "SATURDAY NIGHT FEVER."
THE COLLAR WAS ALL LARGE
AND IN CHARGE,
AND I COULDN'T CONTROL
THIS THING,
SO I FOUND
SOME ORDINARY PAPER CLIPS,
AND I FOUND SOME MAGNETS,
AND I MADE THE VERY FIRST
MAGNETIC COLLAR STAY.
I HAVEN'T WORN A SHIRT
THE SAME SINCE.
SO FIRST YOU TAKE
OUR POWER STAY...
AND YOU PLACE IT ON
THE UNDERSIDE OF THE COLLAR.
THERE'S A COLLAR STAY POCKET.
FLIP THE COLLAR DOWN,
AND WE HAVE
A SUPERSTRONG, SMALL MAGNET,
AND THIS GOES ON THE INSIDE
OF THE SHIRT...
AND INSTANTLY CHANGED
MY SHIRT
INTO
A HIDDEN BUTTON‐DOWN COLLAR.
SO WHEREVER YOU PUT
YOUR COLLAR
IS WHERE YOUR COLLAR STAYS.
AND THERE'S NOTHING ELSE LIKE
THIS IN THE MENSWEAR INDUSTRY.
THESE ARE SPECTACULAR.
THANK YOU. WE KNEW WE HAD
SOMETHING PRETTY SPECIAL
WHEN WE ACQUIRED THREE
HIGH‐END MEN'S SPECIALTY STORES.
WHAT RETAILERS
DO YOU SELL THEM IN?
NORDSTROM CONTACTED US. WE DID
A TEST OF OUR POWER STAYS,
WHICH LAUNCHED IN 24 STORES.
WITHIN 3 MONTHS,
WE WENT TO 77 STORES.
WE HAD SOLD
OVER 18,000 UNITS.
WE MADE THEM
OVER $600,000 RETAIL.
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN
ALL 115 NORDSTROM STORES.
JONATHAN, YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL.
OH, YEAH.
I‐I AM THE REAL DEAL.
I DESIGN AND PRODUCE
ALL THIS STUFF MYSELF.
THE PACKAGING, THE DISPLAYS,
THE PRODUCT‐‐IT'S ALL ME.
JONATHAN, WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
TODAY IN ALL THE PRODUCTS?
THE OTHER DAY‐‐TODAY
I'M AT A HALF MILLION.
I'M EXPECTING $1.8 MILLION
NEXT YEAR.
$1.8 MILLION? WOW.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH THE $85,000?
DAYMOND,
OUT OF ANYBODY HERE,
YOU SHOULD KNOW‐‐
WHAT CAN I DO WITH $85,000?
I MEAN, TO REALLY TAKE
THIS BRAND TO THE NEXT LEVEL,
I NEED TO GET SOMEONE THAT KNOWS
WHAT THE HELL THEY'RE DOING
TO GET ME THERE,
SO I CAN CONTINUE TO CREATE.
I'VE GOT PRODUCTS
ON THE DRAWING BOARD.
I'VE GOT PRODUCTS RIGHT NOW
STILL IN DEVELOPMENT.
JONATHAN,
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
OKAY. OKAY.
I LOVE YOUR PASSION. I LOVE YOUR
KNOWLEDGE. I LOVE YOUR APPROACH.
I'M WAITING FOR THE "BUT."
YEAH, THERE'S A "BUT" COMING.
I'M NOT THE GUY
WITH THE CONNECTIONS.
WHO ADDS VALUE.
I'M JUST NOT THE GUY
TO HELP YOU. I'M OUT.
JONATHAN, I JUST‐‐I REALLY CAN'T
DO ANYTHING FOR YOUR BUSINESS...
OKAY.
SO I'M OUT.
THE GUY THAT'S STAYING
THE MOST QUIET IS THE ONE
THAT CAN HELP ME THE MOST,
BUT HE'S STAYING QUIET.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000
FOR 30% OF THE BUSINESS, BUT...
I WANT A ROYALTY
ON THAT MONEY.
I WANT A 14% ROYALTY.
SO IT'S LIKE A LOAN.
NO. I'M GETTING A TON OF EQUITY,
TOO. I WANT 30% OF THE COMPANY.
IT'S A LOAN, RIGHT?
NO, IT'S NOT A LOAN.
ROBERT'S GIVING ME THE EYE
THAT IT'S A LOAN.
(laughs)
WELL, YOU'RE PAYING 14%
OFF THE TOP. I MEAN...
YOU KNOW, I LOVE ROBERT.
HE LOVES TO GIVE‐‐
I LOVE ROBERT, TOO!
ROBERT GIVES YOU THE EYE,
BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY MONEY.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. IN THE END,
YOU NEED CASH, MY FRIEND.
I'M MAKING YOU AN OFFER.
NEVER DISRESPECT THE CASH.
DON'T LIKE THAT DEAL.
YOU KNOW WHY I LIKE THAT DEAL?
BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA NEED MORE CASH.
YOU'RE GONNA BE CALLING ME
EVERY 90 DAYS FOR
A QUARTER OF A MILLION DOLLARS.
AND IF THINGS ARE GOING WELL,
I'LL KEEP DOING IT.
BUT NOT‐‐NOT AT‐‐YEAH, YEAH.
YEAH, RIGHT, EXACTLY.
ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE AN OFFER.
THAT'S ON THE TABLE.
GREAT. ANYONE ELSE?
WHY DON'T YOU LIKE HIS OFFER?
I NEED MORE THAN MONEY.
I NEED SOMEONE THAT CAN HELP ME.
DAYMOND, YOU‐‐YOU SOLD HATS.
ONE PRODUCT, RIGHT? AND THEN YOU
CREATED THIS EMPIRE OF A BRAND.
(Robert) OOH.
SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT ME
LIKE I CAN'T MAKE THIS
INTO A SUCCESSFUL BRAND.
THAT'S WHAT I DON'T GET.
I DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM.
I DIDN'T SAY YOU CAN'T MAKE IT
INTO A SUCCESSFUL BRAND.
I‐‐
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUCCESSFUL
HAVE THOUGHTS OF HIGH VALUE,
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
HAVE THOUGHTS OF LOW VALUE,
SO YOU'RE VALUING YOURSELF
HIGH‐‐
HOW AM I VALUING MYSELF HIGH?
85 THOUS‐‐
YOU SHOULD BE, BUT IF YOU'RE
GONNA ARGUE WITH ME...
ALL RIGHT.
THEN I DON'T WANT A PARTNER
WHO'S GONNA ARGUE WITH ME...
I'M NOT‐‐I'M‐‐DAYMOND...
SO JUST‐‐BECAUSE OF THAT...
YOU, OUT OF ANYBODY, SHOULD
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M DOING.
I MEAN, I DON'T‐‐
I DON'T GET IT.
I WAS ACTUALLY GONNA THROW
AN OFFER ON THE TABLE‐‐
NOW HE'S GONNA SAY
BECAUSE I WAS ARGUING...
(Barbara) LET DAYMOND TALK.
YOU SEE HIS HAND RIGHT THERE?
I STILL AM NOT DONE TALKING.
I'M OUT.
I‐I KNEW IT.
JONATHAN, YOU'VE ABSOLUTELY
PISSED HIM OFF.
TO CLARIFY WHAT I WAS
TRYING TO TELL YOU
WAS THE REASON THAT
YOU WILL BE WEALTHY
IS BECAUSE YOU HAVE
THOUGHTS OF HIGH VALUE.
I WAS TRYING TO GIVE YOU
A COMPLIMENT.
OKAY.
WHEN I WAS TRYING TO TALK,
I COULD NOT SPEAK TO YOU.
YOU TOOK FOREVER.
I'M‐‐I'M WAITING FOR‐‐
(laughter)
(Jonathan) I'M JUST SAYING...
BOOM GOES THE DYNAMITE!
I'M SORRY. AND I'M SORRY, AND I
WILL NEVER TAKE FOREVER AGAIN,
BECAUSE I WAS GONNA
GIVE YOU AN OFFER,
AND YOU BOTCHED THE OFFER.
OH, WHAT A BABY.
MY GOD.
YOU WANT ME TO GET ON
THE PHONE WITH HIM EVERY DAY?
"HEY, CAN I TALK TO..."
(imitates babbling) "CLICK."
I'LL PUT IT IN THE CONTRACT
I'LL NEVER CALL YOU AGAIN.
HOW'S THAT SOUND?
(laughter)
I CANNOT STAND PARTNERS
THAT I CAN'T EVEN SPEAK TO.
IF HE WOULD HAVE SHUT UP,
HE WOULD HAVE HAD AN OFFER.
I'M GONNA APOLOGIZE, FOR REAL.
I APOLOGIZE. I DIDN'T MEAN
TO COME OFF THAT WAY. IF I'VE
OFFENDED YOU IN ANY WAY...
YOU DID NOT OFFEN‐‐
THEN I WOULD DO
NOTHING DIFFERENT.
YOU DID NOT OFFEND ME.
I'M NOT OFFENDED.
MY FEELINGS AREN'T HURT‐‐
I'M‐‐I'M JUST‐‐
I THINK YOU'RE MISSING OUT
ON A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
(Barbara) COME ON, DAYMOND.
YOU'RE SUCH A BABY. CUT IT OUT.
LISTEN, BARB.
I HAVE PET PEEVES. YOU DO.
IF THIS IS A PET PEEVE,
GET OVER IT.
WOW, YOU REALLY HURT
HIS FEELINGS, JONATHAN.
LET ME TALK TO ROBERT,
MY LAST CHANCE, AND THEN‐‐
AND THEN‐‐SIT THERE AND JUST
THINK ABOUT IT. I'M A NICE GUY.
THEN I'LL
STOP TALKING. OKAY.
JONATHAN, IT'S NOT THE FIRST
TIME YOU'VE HEARD THAT, IS IT?
"NO"? OH, YEAH. I WOULDN'T BE
HERE IF I TOOK NO FOR AN ANSWER.
NEXT.
I'M ACTUALLY UPSET.
YOU KNOW WHY? 'CAUSE I LIKE IT.
WELL, AND I LIKE...
WHATEVER.
SEE? (high‐pitched voice)
"WHATEVER."
I MEAN‐‐NO, I WOULD
TALK TO YOU, BUT YOU‐‐
"YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK
WE SHOULD DO WITH THE COMP‐‐"
(high‐pitched voice)
"WHATEVER."
NO, NO, NOT WHATEVER. DAYMOND,
I'M HERE TO... ALL RIGHT.
DAYMOND, HE'S NERVOUS.
HE'S A HIGH‐ENERGY GUY.
WHY DON'T YOU CUT HIM
A LITTLE SLACK?
WHY DON'T YOU CUT HIM A CHECK?
THIS IS ALL WONDERFUL. LET'S
HOLD HANDS AND SAY "KUMBAYA."
JONATHAN, DO YOU WANT
MY $100,000 OR NOT?
(man) JONATHAN HAS
AN OFFER FROM KEVIN,
BUT THE ONE SHARK HE MOST
WANTED TO DEAL WITH IS OUT.
DO YOU WANT
MY $100,000 OR NOT?
JONATHAN,
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $100,000
FOR 30%, NO ROYALTY.
WOULD YOU GO $200,000
FOR 30%?
WAIT A SECOND. I'LL DROP
MY EQUITY ASSET DOWN.
$100,000 FOR 20%, BUT I WANT
THE ROYALTY TO STAY IN PLACE.
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT HE WANTS. HE'S A SAVAGE.
HE'S ASKING FOR
A THIRD OF YOUR BUSINESS.
YOU'RE A VULTURE!
(Mark laughs)
BECAUSE, I MEAN, I SHOULD
BE GETTING THE ROYALTY HERE.
I MEAN, I'M THE ONE
THAT'S CREATING THE STUFF.
JONATHAN, I'LL GIVE YOU
$100,000 FOR 25%.
UH, THAT'S MY FINAL OFFER.
(Barbara) ONE MORE THING.
I'M GONNA GO BACK IN.
BARBARA!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YEAH.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $100,000
FOR 20%,
PROVIDED DAYMOND FORGIVES YOU.
AND I'LL BE
YOUR FRONT MAN, DAYMOND.
YOU NEVER HAVE TO TALK TO THIS
GUY. YOU JUST ENJOY HIS SUCCESS.
AND YOU KNOW
I'M A GREAT FRONT MAN.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
OH, DAYMOND.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH PERCENTAGE
ON THE COMPANY.
WHAT‐‐SO WHAT IS IT?
YOU WANT TO MATCH HIS AT 25%?
CAN'T TAKE LESS THAN 40%.
(O'Leary) WHOO!
(Robert) OH, MY...
WOW.
JONATHAN, COME BACK TO DADDY!
(Robert laughs)
COME BACK TO DADDY!
I'M PUTTING A DIFFERENCE
OF ONLY 15% DUE TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
THAT'S ALL.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
OKAY, I'LL DROP
MY EQUITY ASSET DOWN TO 15%,
BUT THE ROYALTY
STAYS IN PLACE.
WOULD‐‐WOULD DAYMOND AND BARBARA
BE WILLING TO DO 30%...
THE $100,000 FOR 30% EQUITY?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THE OFFER'S A HARD OFFER.
JONATHAN, JONATHAN.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION NOW.
YES, I WOULD LIKE TO DO A DEAL
WITH BARBARA AND DAYMOND.
GREAT.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
(Barbara)
AW, THAT'S A HAPPY ENDING.
(Jonathan) THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT? I DEAL WITH
CREATIVE GUYS LIKE DESIGNERS.
YOU WILL NEVER GET A WORD IN,
AND YOU'LL NEVER
GET ANYTHING DONE.
YOU WERE SPANKING HIM
LIKE A BABY SEAL.
(laughs)
I ALMOST BLEW THE DEAL WITH
DAYMOND BECAUSE OF MY BIG MOUTH.
BARBARA, LOVE YA.
THANK YOU
FOR GETTING THAT HOOK OUT
AND GETTING DAYMOND BACK
INTO THE GAME. APPRECIATE IT.
(man) LAST SEASON,
WE WATCHED MARK FURIGAY
MAKE A $250,000 DEAL
WITH THE SHARKS,
SPEARHEADED BY KEVIN O'LEARY.
YOU'RE A VERY WISE MAN.
LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
WE'RE HERE AT THE NUMBER ONE
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY ON EARTH.
THESE ARE THE HEADQUARTERS
OF HOUGHTON MIFFLIN HARCOURT.
(O'Leary) DUE TO THE RECESSION,
THEY WERE NOT OPEN
TO HEARING MARC'S PITCH,
BUT WITH THE RECENT UPTAKE
IN THE ECONOMY,
I FINALLY GOT US IN THE DOOR
FOR A MEETING
WITH THEIR ENTIRE BOARD.
MARK, DON'T SCREW THAT UP.
(guitar playing chords)
WHAT IS "CLASSROOM JAMS"?
"CLASSROOM JAMS" ARE ORIGINAL
SONGS THAT DELIVER CURRICULUM.
"CLASSROOM JAMS" TAKES DIFFICULT
SUBJECTS LIKE SHAKESPEARE
AND SETS THEM TO COOL MUSIC
TO TURN KIDS ON TO LEARNING.
♪ WHOA, I'VE GOT ♪
♪ LADY MACBETH BLUES ♪
BEING HERE MEANS
EVERYTHING TO ME.
I'VE WORKED REALLY, REALLY HARD,
BUT I'VE ONLY COME SO FAR.
NOW, WITH KEVIN'S HELP,
I'M IN FRONT OF
THE TOP EXECUTIVES OF THE TOP
EDUCATIONAL FIRM IN THE WORLD.
THIS IS
A PRETTY BIG OPPORTUNITY.
♪ WHOA,
WHAT'S A LADY GOTTA DO? ♪
(song ends)
(applause)
UH, I THINK,
AS A GROUP HERE,
WE'RE, UH, CERTAINLY RECEPTIVE
TO GIVING MARC A CHANCE
TO SEE IF THIS HAS
SOME, UH, SUSTAINABILITY.
WONDERFUL.
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SHOW
THAT STUDENTS LEARN BETTER
THAN A TRADITIONAL METHOD,
SO THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT
IS FOR US TO RUN A PILOT.
I'D SAY THAT'S SUCCESS, MARK.
THANK YOU.
I AM SUPER‐GRATEFUL.
THIS IS A ONCE‐IN‐A‐LIFETIME
OPPORTUNITY.
I NEVER COULD HAVE
GOTTEN THERE WITHOUT KEVIN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
CONGRATULATIONS. LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER.
(Mark) THANKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HE PULLED IT OFF,
AND WE HAVE A NATIONAL TEST.
I CAN SMELL
THE MONEY ALREADY.
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS MEGAN REILLY AND SARAH NUSE
WITH AN INNOVATIVE WAY
FOR STAY‐AT‐HOME MOMS
TO MAKE MONEY.
(laughter)
HI.
MY NAME IS SARAH NUSE...
AND I'M HER SISTER,
MEGAN REILLY.
AND WE ARE SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
OF $30,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR 5% STAKE OF OUR CHILDREN'S
DANCE COMPANY, TIPPI TOES.
ONE IN FIVE CHILDREN
IN AMERICA ARE OBESE,
AND 80% OF ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
HAVE CUT RECESS.
OUR FUN, KID‐FRIENDLY,
HIGH‐ENERGY DANCING AND MUSIC
GETS THE KIDS MOVING AND FEELING
GOOD ABOUT THEMSELVES.
OKAY, KIDS, YOU READY
TO DO SOME DANCING?
READY!
(chuckles)
(bells ringing, snoring)
(woman, singsongy) WAKE UP!
(man, singsongy) WAKE UP!
WAKE UP, SKIPPY!
(child) WAKE UP, TIPPI!
(calypso music playing)
(woman) ♪ JUMP OUT OF BED ♪
♪ SAY HELLO TO THE SUN ♪
(chuckles)
♪ WIGGLE YOUR BODY ♪
♪ AND GO FOR A RUN ♪
♪ IT'S A HOOLA BOOLA,
HOOLA BOOLA, HOOLA TI DAY ♪
♪♪♪
♪ I LOVE TIPPI TOES ♪
♪ AND EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT'S RIGHT ♪
(music stops)
(Megan) YAY! YOU GUYS DID SUCH
A GOOD JOB! THAT WAS PERFECT!
(Barbara) MORE, MORE.
(Mark) YAY.
NOW WE NEED YOU GUYS
TO DANCE YOUR WAY OUT OF HERE
BEFORE ONE OF THESE SHARKS
TRY TO BITE YOU. SAY GOOD‐BYE!
(Robert) GOOD JOB, GUYS.
BYE!
(laughter)
AS A FORMER
PROFESSIONAL DANCER MYSELF,
AND MEGAN BEING
A REGISTERED DIETICIAN,
WE FOCUS OUR BUSINESS
ON PHYSICAL ACTIVITY,
HEALTHY HABITS,
AND, MOST IMPORTANTLY,
THE KIDS HAVING FUN.
AND IN 2009, WE BEGAN
FRANCHISING OUR BUSINESS
SO WE COULD REACH
AS MANY KIDS AS POSSIBLE.
AND AS LONG AS PEOPLE
KEEP HAVING BABIES,
WE'RE ALWAYS
GONNA HAVE CUSTOMERS.
NOW WHICH ONE OF YOU SHARKS
IS READY TO INVEST IN US?
YOU SAID YOU SOLD 70 FRANCHISES?
DID I HEAR THAT RIGHT?
SEVEN FRANCHISES.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT. WHAT DO YOU CHARGE?
IT'S $30,000 TO GET IN.
OUR VISION IS
THE STAY‐AT‐HOME MOM.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT TIPPI TOES
IS WE GO INTO PRESCHOOLS,
AFTER‐SCHOOL ACTIVITIES,
UM, DAY CARE,
SO WE DON'T HAVE
OVERHEAD OF A FACILITY,
SO IT'S A LOW ENTRY COST,
AND THEN, THEY PAY
A MONTHLY ROYALTY FEE TO US.
SARAH, $30,000 ISN'T THAT LOW.
WHAT DO I GET FOR THAT $30,000?
$30,000‐‐
WE CREATED OUR OWN MUSIC.
WE HAVE, UM, OUR FIRST CD,
"TIPPI'S TUNES"‐‐
THAT'S A LESSON PLAN. UM,
WE GO OUT AND DO THE BUSINESS,
THE SALES AND MARKETING
FOR THEM, THEY GET OUR‐‐
SO I GIVE YOU $30,000,
YOU GIVE ME A CD,
AND I GET PICTURES
OF THE INSECTS?
THEY'RE NOT INSECTS. THEY'RE
ADORABLE LITTLE CREATURES.
SO RATHER THAN TAKING THEM
TO DANCE CLASS SOMEWHERE ELSE...
CORRECT.
YOU'RE‐‐YOU HAVE A LICENSEE
WHO SAYS TO MY KID'S PRESCHOOL,
"YOU KEEP THE KIDS THERE."
MM‐HMM.
RIGHT? I'M GONNA CHARGE
THE PARENTS INDEPENDENTLY.
THE PRESCHOOL OR SCHOOL IS JUST
GONNA LET ME USE THE FACILITIES
BECAUSE IT'S JUST
A GOOD THING FOR THEM TO DO
TO KEEP THEIR KIDS THERE...
YEAH, EXACTLY.
AND THEN IT'S A WIN‐WIN.
IT'S VERY CLEVER. HOW MUCH MONEY
DOES YOUR COMPANY MAKE TODAY?
LAST YEAR WE MADE $268,000.
AND WHAT WAS YOUR PROFIT?
OUR PROFIT WAS $29,000.
THE $30,000 THEY HAVE TO PAY
FOR THE FRANCHISE...
CORRECT.
WHERE DO PEOPLE GET THAT MONEY?
UM, A LOT OF WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS WE'VE DONE IT IN‐HOUSE, WHERE
WE'LL FINANCE IT OUT FOR 'EM.
THEN, WE CAN MAKE MONEY
OFF THEIR INTEREST, WHICH‐‐
SO, YOU MEAN THEY OWE YOU
THE $30,000...
CORRECT.
AND THEN YOU START CHAR‐‐
LIKE, YOU GUYS ARE UNBELIEVABLE.
YOU ARE SHARKS.
YOU MARCH INTO SOMEBODY
AND YOU SELL THEM
$30,000 WORTH OF LIABILITY THEY
START PAYING YOU INTEREST ON
'CAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
FUNDED IT YET.
FORGET THIS. COME AND WORK
FOR ME AT O'LEARY FUNDS.
(laughter)
I CAN MAKE YOU
SOME REAL MONEY.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU
WHAT'S PROPRIETARY ABOUT THIS?
WHY CAN'T I‐‐
DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY'RE PROPRIETARY ABOUT THIS.
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE TRIED THIS.
PEOPLE HEARD ABOUT US.
THEY MAKE UP A NAME
THAT'S NOT NEARLY, OF COURSE,
AS CUTE AS "TIPPI TOES."
YEAH, "UNCLE KEVIN'S
WACKY FEET."
EXACTLY. BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU DON'T HAVE THIS PASSION,
YOU DON'T HAVE THIS DRIVE,
YOU AREN'T THIS GOOD WITH KIDS.
WE HAVE IT.
I MEAN, I‐I'M ABSOLUTELY
BLOWN AWAY YOU'VE GOT
A QUARTER OF A MILLION DOLLARS
OF SALES, 'CAUSE THIS STUFF‐‐
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IT PROVES,
KEVIN? WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF HARD WORK, A LITTLE BIT
OF PASSION, AND A LITTLE BIT
OF VISION, YOU CAN‐‐
YOU CAN HAVE A REAL BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW WHAT? WE HAVE SO MANY
PARENTS COME TO US WHO SAY,
"WE DID DANCE SOMEPLACE ELSE.
THIS IS LIKE NOTHING ELSE
WE'VE EVER SEEN."
WHAT'S YOUR ONGOING ROYALTY
THAT YOU'RE EARNING BACK
FROM THE‐‐THE FRANCHISEE?
THERE'S A MINIMUM ROYALTY
PAYMENT EACH MONTH, SO‐‐
TELL ME WHAT
YOUR MINIMUM ROYALTY IS.
IT'S $1,000 EACH MONTH.
WHA‐‐ARE YOU ACTUALLY‐‐
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS!
SEE, KEVIN?
THESE GUYS ARE GOOD!
THESE GUYS ARE GOOD,
I'M TELLING YOU.
THAT'S $42,000. (laughs)
I CAN'T BELIEVE PEOPLE GIVE YOU
$30,000 FOR THESE INSECTS!
THESE GUYS ARE LIKE
EXTORTIONISTS WITH TUTUS ON.
I LOVE 'EM.
(laughs)
YOU ASKED FOR $30,000 FOR 5%.
MM‐HMM.
TALK TO ME
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHY THIS BUSINESS
IS WORTH $600,000.
WE WALKED IN THE DOORS
A FEW MINUTES AGO.
SINCE THEN, WE HAVE
MORE KIDS IN "TIPPI TOES,"
SO WE ARE GROWING
AT A RAPID PACE.
(chuckles)
LOVE THAT ATTITUDE.
AND WHY ARE YOU
ONLY GIVING US 5%?
IF YOU WANT MORE,
NEGOTIATE WITH US.
(Mark and Barbara laugh)
BOY, THAT'S GREAT.
ARE THESE DVDs OR CDs?
THESE ARE CDs THAT WE HAVE
HERE. WE HOPE TO DO DVDs.
SO YOU HAVEN'T
PRODUCED THE DVDs YET?
THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE HERE‐‐TODAY.
OH, I SEE.
OH, WOW.
BUT GUYS, GUYS, WHY? YOU KNOW,
WHY GET INTO THE DVD BUSINESS,
WHEREAS, YOU MIGHT MAKE, $5 TO
$10 A DVD IF YOU'RE LUCKY.
THAT'S WHERE‐‐
THAT'S OUR VISION.
IT'S DOWN THE R‐‐WE'RE BUILDING
A BRAND. WE'RE BUILDING A BRAND.
IS THAT WHERE
YOU'RE GOING WITH IT?
(Megan) THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
GOING WITH IT. LONG‐TERM.
OUR BIG DREAM IS TO HAVE
THE NEXT BARNEY.
YOU GUYS ARE AMAZING,
WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
SELLING THEM ANYTHING
EXCEPT YOUR SMILING FACES.
(laughs) I HOPE YOU SEE MORE
BEHIND IT THAN THAT.
I DON'T, ACTUALLY.
THE REST OF US DO,
BUT DON'T WORRY, GUYS.
IF YOU KEEP ON GOING
LIKE YOU ARE,
HE'LL NEED A JOB,
AND YOU CAN HIRE HIM.
YES, YES. THAT'LL WORK.
GUYS, YOU DON'T NEED ME,
BUT YOU ARE GREAT EXTORTIONISTS.
UM, I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
DO WELL. I'M OUT.
HAVE ANY OF THE PEOPLE
YOU SIGNED UP QUIT?
AS FAR AS FRANCHISEES?
YEAH.
(both) NO.
AND HOW LONG IS
THE‐‐THE, UH...
TEN YEARS.
TEN YEARS. REALLY? OKAY.
MM‐HMM. MM‐HMM. AND THEN,
AT THE END OF 10 YEARS‐‐
IT'S A 10‐YEAR COMMITMENT?
AT THE END OF TEN YEARS,
THEIR BUSINESS IS THRIVING.
WOW.
THEY SIGN ANOTHER...
(O'Leary laughs)
THIS IS UN‐‐THIS IS UNREAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER TO
APPLAUD THEM OR CALL THE POLICE.
(laughs)
THEY'RE DOING
THE HARDEST THING IN THE WORLD
FOR ANY SMALL BUSINESS.
THEY'RE EXECUTING ON THEIR IDEA.
HOW DO YOU STOP THEM FROM
FOLLOWING THE DVD DEAL?
HOW DO YOU STOP THEM
FROM DOING THAT?
WELL, THEN,
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE, RIGHT?
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET
TOO FAR AHEAD OF YOURSELF...
SURE.
OKAY.
'CAUSE THAT'S
HOW YOU SCREW UP.
SARAH, IT'S FANTASTIC, BUT YOU
GOT TO GROW ONE STEP AT A TIME.
YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T BUILD
A GREAT BUSINESS OVERNIGHT,
AND I THINK YOU'RE JUST TRYING
TO TAKE TOO BIG A LEAP. I'M OUT.
I CAN'T GET NEAR YOUR VALUATION.
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE FOR ME.
YET, I'M SO STUNNED BY WHAT
YOU'VE DONE... TO PEOPLE‐‐
YOU GOT THEM TO SIGN
THESE CONTRACTS.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $50,000 FOR 51%.
(scoffs)
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
WEAR ANKLE BRACELETS,
AND EVERY TIME YOU MENTION‐‐
YOU MENTION THE WORD "DVD"?
24‐VOLT SHOCK.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
AND YOU STAY IN THE CARS
AND YOU SIGN THOSE CONTRACTS.
THE PROBLEM IS 5%, EVEN ON
A BUSINESS THAT'S GROWING.
OKAY.
YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO COME BACK TO ME,
AND, VERY SIMPLY, IF YOU COME
BACK WITH THE RIGHT NUMBER...
(Barbara) FOR $30,000?
MAN, YOU DO THIS ALL THE TIME.
WELL, I THINK THE GENIUS
OF THIS WHOLE THING
IS THAT YOU'VE FOUND A WAY
TO TAP INTO THE WORKING MOM
WHILE HER KIDS
ARE AT SCHOOL.
MM‐HMM.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S
A LIMIT TO WHAT YOU COULD DO.
BUT I THINK
THE 5% ISN'T ENOUGH
TO GET ME EXCITED
TO BE IN WITH YOU.
OKAY.
SO I NEED
A LARGER PERCENTAGE.
SO RATHER THAN ASK YOU
TO NAME A NUMBER BACK TO ME,
I'M GONNA SAY THAT I'D LIKE
TO GET 20% OF YOUR BUSINESS...
OKAY.
FOR... WHAT? $60,000?
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
UM, THANK YOU FOR YOUR OFFER,
BUT NO, THANK YOU.
YOU SURE?
(Mark) BEFORE YOU COME BACK‐‐
ARE YOU GOING TO COME BACK
AND MAKE A COUNTER‐OFFER?
MM‐HMM.
OKAY. BEFORE YOU COME BACK
WITH A COUNTEROFFER,
HERE'S THE SCENARIO.
OKAY.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO
A NEGOTIATION, AND A COMPETITIVE
NEGOTIATION, VERSUS BARBARA,
SO IF I SAY YES TO WHATEVER
YOUR COUNTER IS, YOU HAVE TO
TELL ME THAT YOU WILL SAY YES
IMMEDIATELY,
AND WE HAVE A DEAL.
OKAY.
I LIKE THAT. THAT'S EXCITING.
I KNOW.
MY PALMS ARE SWEATING.
YES? IS THAT A YES?
YES.
OKAY.
OKAY. SO $100,000...
NOW WAIT A MINUTE...
FOR 30%.
DONE. DONE AND DONE.
CRAP.
THANK YOU AND GOOD NIGHT!
(both scream)
OH, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S GONNA BE FUN.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
(both screaming and laughing)
DID YOU LIKE THAT, BARBARA?
I DON'T LIKE IT ONE BIT.
(laughs)
THAT WAS SO DAMN SMART. I‐‐
NO, BUT THAT'S
A COMPLIMENT TO YOU,
BECAUSE I DID NOT WANT TO GET
IN A BACK‐AND‐FORTH WITH YOU.
WELL, THANK YOU.
IT FEELS SO GOOD.
"BARBARA, I SCREWED YOU,
BUT IT'S A COMPLIMENT TO YOU!"
I FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT IT.
I'M JUST A LEAN, MEAN
SHARK MACHINE, BABY!
(both scream)
OH, MY GOSH.
WE'RE SO EXCITED.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
MORE THAN WE EVER IMAGINED.
AND THEY'RE‐‐THE SHARKS,
THEY'RE‐‐THEY'RE TOUGH,
BUT THEY'RE NOT THAT TOUGH.
FELT GOOD ABOUT IT.
THEY GOT OUR VISION.
♪♪♪
I'M SHAWN DAVIS,
BETTER KNOWN AS CHEF BIG SHAKE,
'CAUSE WHEN I'M IN THE KITCHEN,
I SHAKE IT LIKE THIS.
(sizzling)
I LEARNED HOW TO COOK GROWING UP
WITH MY ITALIAN FAMILY.
YOU HEARD ME‐‐
MY ITALIAN FAMILY.
I GREW UP IN A PRETTY ROUGH AREA
IN NEW YORK. AT THE AGE OF 12,
MY MOTHER MADE ARRANGEMENTS FOR
ME TO MOVE IN WITH THE PALMEROS.
GIOVANNI PALMERO OWNED A VERY
SUCCESSFUL ITALIAN RESTAURANT.
HE TAUGHT ME EVERYTHING
ABOUT THE RESTAURANT BUSINESS.
THAT'S WHERE I DEVELOPED
MY STRONG PASSION OF COOKING
AND DEVELOPING FOOD PRODUCTS.
NOT TOO THIN. THERE YOU GO.
LET THE KNIFE DO THE WORK.
NOW I HAVE
A FAMILY OF MY OWN.
IT WAS FOR MY DAUGHTER
THAT I WAS INSPIRED TO MAKE
THIS HEALTHIER ALTERNATIVE
TO THE BURGER,
AND THERE'S NOTHING OUT THERE
LIKE IT.
C.B.S. FOODS.
MY DREAM IS TO BRING
A LITTLE BIT OF CHEF BIG SHAKE
TO EVERY SINGLE DINNER TABLE
ACROSS AMERICA.
♪♪♪
WHAT'S UP, WHAT'S UP,
WHAT'S UP, PEOPLE?
MY NAME IS SHAWN DAVIS,
BETTER KNOWN AS CHEF BIG SHAKE.
I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF C. B. S. FOODS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR $200,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 25%
OF MY BUSINESS.
OUR FLAGSHIP PRODUCT IS
THE ORIGINAL SHRIMP BURGER.
WE MANUFACTURE THESE BURGERS
TODAY IN FOUR DIFFERENT FLAVORS.
WE HAVE
ORIGINAL, TERIYAKI, CAJUN,
AND JALAPEÑO,
IF YOU LIKE IT HOT.
TODAY I BROUGHT SOME SAMPLES
FOR YOU GUYS TO TRY.
HEY, SHAKE,
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MMM.
TASTES GOOD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TO DATE, WE'VE SOLD OVER
22,000 UNITS OF THESE BURGERS
TO MOM‐AND‐POP STORES
AND THE RESTAURANTS.
THE SALES HAVE GROSSED
RIGHT AROUND 30 GRAND.
THIS YEAR, I RECOGNIZED
THE BIGGER PICTURE.
MY BURGER NEEDS TO BE
IN EVERY SINGLE SUPERMARKET
ACROSS AMERICA.
THESE ARE THE FACTS‐‐
THE HAMBURGER BUSINESS IS
A MULTIBILLION‐DOLLAR‐A‐YEAR
BUSINESS. TURKEY BURGER‐‐
A BILLION‐DOLLAR‐A‐YEAR
BUSINESS.
BANKRUPTCY LAWYERS‐‐
A BILLION‐DOLLAR‐A‐YEAR
BUSINESS.
(chuckles)
(chuckles) C. B. S. FOODS HAS
PERFECTLY POSITIONED OURSELVES
TO GROW THE SHRIMP BURGER
TO A BILLION‐DOLLAR‐A‐YEAR
BUSINESS,
JUST LIKE ITS COUNTERPARTS.
WHO'S READY TO HELP ME
HELP YOU ADD SOME ZEROS
TO YOUR BOTTOM LINE?
(O'Leary) SO WALK ME THROUGH
WHAT A CASE COSTS TO MAKE
AND WHAT YOU SELL IT FOR.
UM, PER BURGER,
87 CENTS A BURGER.
THAT'S NOT CHEAP.
AND WE RETAIL IT FOR $1.63.
IT'S PROTEIN. IT'S SHRIMP.
LITTLE LIGHT
ON THE MARGINS THERE.
WELL, LET ME TELL YOU THIS.
THIS IS NOT
A ONE‐DIMENSIONAL PRODUCT.
YOU'RE BUYING A BRAND.
YOU'RE BUYING C. B. S. FOODS.
WE'RE BUYING SHAWN.
YOU'RE BUYING
CHEF BIG SHAKE.
AND WHAT OTHER PRODUCTS
ARE UNDER C. B. S.?
THE LOBSTER SLIDER, WHICH
THEY'VE TAKEN 300 CASES OF.
COLLECTIVELY, ALL OF MY MARGINS,
ALL PUT TOGETHER,
ALL OF OUR PRODUCTS,
IS RUNNING RIGHT AROUND 63%.
HOW IS THIS BUSINESS WORTH
$800,000 TODAY?
YOU'VE ONLY GOT $30,000
IN SALES.
YOU'RE NOT MAKING ANY MONEY.
WHAT I HAVE IS COMMITMENTS
FROM TWO SUPERMARKETS
THAT SAID TO ME‐‐
THEY FLEW ME IN AFTER TASTING
EXACTLY WHAT YOU TASTED
AND SAID, "YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE WANT YOU IN HERE."
SO THESE ARE ONLY
2 SUPERMARKETS OUT OF 32,000
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE THAT ORDER.
I WILL HAVE THIS ORDER
WITHIN THE NEXT TEN DAYS.
AND THAT ORDER WILL BE HOW BIG?
FOR THE BURGERS, 600 CASES,
AND FOR THE SLIDERS, 300 CASES.
WHAT WOULD THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
OF THOSE ORDERS BE?
$87,200.
SO YOU'VE GOT $30,000
IN SALES THIS YEAR.
YES.
LET'S SAY IT'S $100,000
IN ORDERS THIS YEAR.
OKAY. OKAY.
HOW MUCH MONEY WILL YOU MAKE
ON $100,000?
I WOULD MAKE ROUGHLY 53%.
(sighs)
(Mark) MAN, I'VE GOTTA SAY,
I LIKE THE CONCEPT.
YOU'VE GOT A CUSTOMER IN ME.
I'LL‐‐I'LL BUY THE PRODUCT.
BUT I REALLY CAN'T ADD VALUE.
I DON'T KNOW THE FOOD BUSINESS.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO SAY
THAT I'M OUT.
(Barbara)
AND, SHAWN, I HAVE TO SAY,
I JUST DON'T LIKE SHRIMP AT ALL,
SO I'M JUST GOING OUT
ON THAT BASIS.
(O'Leary) YOU AND I ARE
ACTUALLY DOING BUSINESS
TOGETHER RIGHT NOW.
YOU JUST DON'T KNOW IT.
I OWN THE DEBT OF ONE
OF THE LARGEST MANUFACTURERS
OF CRUSTACEAN AND PROTEINS
OFF THE BOTTOM OF THE OCEAN.
I ALWAYS KNEW YOU WERE
A BOTTOM‐FEEDER, KEVIN.
SHAWN, MY CONCERN
IS YOUR MARGINS...
YES, SIR.
AREN'T HIGH ENOUGH.
THEY HAVE TO BE NORTH OF 70%
IN SEAFOOD, BECAUSE IT REQUIRES
A HEAVY COMMITMENT
TO REFRIGERATION AND STORAGE
AND ALSO ACCESS TO SUPPLY
OF THE PROTEIN YOU'RE USING,
WHICH IS
THE MOST EXPENSIVE FOOD WE EAT
AND THE MOST VULNERABLE TO
PRICE INCREASES AND DECREASES.
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY,
UM, TO ME, WHILE IT'S
AN INTERESTING FOOD CONCEPT,
IT'S PROBABLY
ONE OF THE MORE RISKY,
AND, UH,
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
OKAY. OKAY.
(Robert)
SHAWN, I LOVE THE PRODUCT.
$200,000 FOR YOUR COMPANY‐‐
I DON'T THINK
YOUR WHOLE COMPANY IS WORTH
$200,000 TO $300,000 TODAY.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BUILD IT
AND IT'S GONNA BE SUCCESSFUL.
THIS IS NOT
A ONE‐DIMENSIONAL PRODUCT.
THESE ARE SHRIMP BURGERS.
AMERICA LOVES SHRIMP.
IT'S THE NUMBER ONE
SEAFOOD PRODUCT.
I LOVE THE SHRIMP.
I HATE THE VALUATION.
THE COMPANY
ISN'T WORTH THAT TODAY.
FOR THAT REASON, UH, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
(man) FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAYMOND JOHN IS
SHAWN'S LAST CHANCE
TO MAKE A DEAL.
DAYMOND?
I LIKED THOSE BURGERS. I‐‐
LOOK, I ATE 'EM. BOTH OF 'EM.
AND I'M GONNA EAT THE OTHER
GUYS' BURGERS WHEN THEY LEAVE.
(sighs) I CAN'T GET AROUND
THE NUMBER THAT YOU'RE ASKING.
YOU'RE VALUATING
YOUR COMPANY AT $800,000.
I CAN'T GET AROUND IT,
SO I HAVE TO SAY...
WELL, I'M WILLING TO‐‐
I'M WILLING TO...
INCREASE THE PERCENTAGE
TO BUY INTO MY COMPANY.
I'M WILLING TO DO THAT.
WHAT PERCENTAGE?
I'M WILLING TO GO UP TO 30%.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO'S
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE PRODUCT.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO LOVES THIS BUSINESS.
WHO STUDIED THIS BUSINESS.
I HAVE THE STRONG PASSION
AND KNOW HOW TO DO IT.
WHAT IF I OFFER 40%
OF THE COMPANY?
EVERYTHING ABOUT YOU IS RIGHT
EXCEPT FOR THAT NUMBER,
AND YOU'RE NOW AT 40%
FOR $200,000,
SO NOW YOU'RE VALUATING
THE COMPANY AT ABOUT...
ROUGHLY $570,000.
$500,000.
YES, SIR. $500,000.
I'D BE BUYING MORE INTO YOU
'CAUSE YOU'RE A GREAT GUY
THAN BUYING
INTO THE BUSINESS...
SO... I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
(O'Leary)
EVEN IF HE HAS THOSE ORDERS,
THE BUSINESS IS NOT WORTH
$500,000.
NO, BUT HE DID HAVE
A BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW, HE'S‐‐
HE'LL GET THERE.
I HOPE HE REALLY MAKES IT.
WELL, WHEN I GET HOME
AND TELL MY FAMILY THAT
I DIDN'T GET THE INVESTMENT,
I THINK INITIALLY THEY'RE GONNA
BE A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
EVERYTHING HAPPENS FOR A REASON.
THIS IS NOT GONNA STOP.
I HAVE A STRONG SUPPORT SYSTEM,
AND I KNOW THEY'LL BE THERE,
AND WE'RE GONNA KEEP CONTINUING
MOVING FORWARD.
♪♪♪
(man)
MY NAME IS JAMES MARTIN.
I LIVE IN
BEAUTIFUL OREGON WINE COUNTRY,
AND MY PRODUCT IS COPA DI VINO.
I COME FROM A FAMILY
OF CHERRY FARMERS,
AND MY FAMILY HAS LIVED HERE
FOR SEVEN GENERATIONS.
I WORKED
IN THE WORLD OF TECHNOLOGY
AND THEN MOVED BACK
TO THE SMALL COMMUNITY
TO TRY TO RAISE A FAMILY
ON THE FARM
AND BECAME PASSIONATE
ABOUT WINE,
WHICH IS
AN AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT,
AND DEVELOPED MY OWN WINERY.
COPA! HEY!
COPA DI VINO WILL MAKE WINE
EASIER AND MORE ACCESSIBLE
FOR PEOPLE TO ENJOY.
OUR TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS WINEMAKERS
TO BE ABLE TO PACKAGE WINE
IN A WAY THAT THEY'VE NEVER
BEEN ABLE TO BEFORE.
I KNOW THAT COPA DI VINO
IS GONNA BE SO SUCCESSFUL
THAT I HOPE TO BE
THE FIRST ENTREPRENEUR
TO ACTUALLY COME BACK
AND BE A SHARK.
♪♪♪
MY NAME'S JAMES MARTIN.
I'M C. E. O. AND FOUNDER
OF COPA DI VINO.
I'M HERE TODAY
LOOKING FOR AN INVESTMENT
OF $600,000
FOR 20% OF MY COMPANY.
I LOVE WINE,
AND IT'S MY FAVORITE WAY
TO CELEBRATE LIFE
WITH MY FAMILY AND FRIENDS,
AND SOME OF THE GREATEST PLACES
TO CELEBRATE LIFE
ARE IN THE OUTDOORS
OR AT EVENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY,
THAT'S WHEN WINE GETS
VERY COMPLICATED.
JUST TO HAVE
A SIMPLE SINGLE GLASS OF WINE,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE WINE BOTTLES,
CORKSCREWS,
AND FRAGILE WINEGLASSES.
THAT'S WHY I CREATED
COPA DI VINO‐‐
AMERICA'S FIRST
PREMIUM WINE BY THE GLASS.
JUST OPEN...
AND ENJOY.
CHEERS.
CUSTOMERS OF WINE
LOVE MY PRODUCT,
BUT FOR BUSINESSES,
THIS IS THE GAME‐CHANGER.
FOR A STADIUM
THAT WANTS TO OFFER
A PREMIUM
WINE‐BY‐THE‐GLASS PRODUCT,
THIS PRODUCT IS THE ONLY VESSEL
THAT ALLOWS YOU
TO HAVE
PREMIUM WINE BY THE GLASS.
I HAVE THE LARGEST RETAILERS
AND VENUES IN THE COUNTRY
BEGGING TO SERVE MY PRODUCT.
I JUST NEED YOUR HELP
TO CREATE MORE INVENTORY.
THIS IS THE MOST REVOLUTIONARY
WINE PACKAGING
CREATED IN THE LAST 20 YEARS.
ARE YOU SELLING US
ON A PACKAGING SYSTEM,
OR ARE YOU TELLING ME
YOU WANT TO ENTER
THE VERY COMPETITIVE
WINE BUSINESS?
I HAVE A WINERY.
IN MY WINERY...
THANK YOU.
CURRENTLY WE MAKE ABOUT
2,500 CASES OF WINE A YEAR,
AND WE'RE NOW CURRENTLY
IN MARKET WITH MY PRODUCT.
IN THE FIRST 6 MONTHS, WE'VE
SOLD PRODUCT INTO 26 STATES
WITH THE LARGEST DISTRIBUTORS
IN THE COUNTRY.
CHEERS, BARBARA.
WAIT UP FOR ME.
(O'Leary) SO YOU GROW
YOUR OWN CHARDONNAY GRAPES
AND CABERNET SAUVIGNON?
I BUY FRUIT FROM MY FRIENDS
THAT HAVE VINEYARDS.
CHEERS.
A TOAST TO ALL OF YOU.
WHOOPS.
SO WAS THAT
THE EASIEST GLASS OF WINE
YOU'VE EVER SERVED YOURSELF?
IT'S A LITTLE HARD
TO TAKE OFF.
NO KIDDING?
JAMES, AM I BUYING
A WINE LABEL HERE,
OR AM I BUYING
A PACKAGING SYSTEM?
WE'RE‐‐ACTUALLY HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT REVENUE STREAMS.
WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO LICENSE
AND‐‐AND COLLECT ROYALTIES,
WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO BOTTLE FOR AN INDUSTRY,
AND WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO GO AHEAD AND LAUNCH
OUR OWN CONSUMER BRAND.
AND WHICH OF THE STREAMS ARE
BRINGING IN SALES TODAY?
AT FIRST, RIGHT NOW, OUR OWN
CONSUMER BRAND, COPA DI VINO.
AND WHAT ARE SALES
IN THAT TODAY?
WELL, WE'VE BEEN IN
THE MARKET FOR FIVE MONTHS,
AND WE'VE HAD
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS OF SALES.
WE'VE HAD OVER $800,000
WORTH OF ORDERS.
WOW.
THAT'S QUICK.
SO PEOPLE ARE BUYING YOUR WINE
BECAUSE IT'S EASY TO CARRY?
ABSOLUTELY,
AND THEY'RE ALSO GETTING‐‐
WHEN THEY'RE DRINKING
MY PRODUCT,
THEY'RE ALSO GETTING A‐A‐‐
DON'T COME AND TELL ME
THIS IS PREMIUM WINE. IT'S NOT.
IT'S JUST INDUSTRIAL WINE.
YEAH, BUT YOU'RE A WINE SNOB.
LET'S BE REAL.
SO WHAT? TO ME, I WOULDN'T BUY
THIS WINE. THAT'S JUST ME.
YOU'RE GOING AFTER
MASS‐MARKET.
I THINK THE PACKAGING
IS THE PLAY.
RIGHT.
HOW LONG DOES IT STAY FRESH?
WE'RE GOOD FOR A YEAR.
THE CHALLENGE WITH ANYTIME
THAT YOU REDUCE IT DOWN
TO A SMALL AMOUNT,
IS THAT THE SHELF LIFE
IS VERY, VERY SHORT.
USUALLY, 30 DAYS.
WELL...
YOU'RE GETTING A YEAR
OUT OF IT.
HAVE YOU PATENTED
THIS PACKAGING?
ABSOLUTELY.
NOT ONLY DID WE CREATE A WAY TO
ATMOSPHERICALLY PACKAGE LIQUID,
WE'VE CREATED A WAY THAT
WHEN ALCOHOL VOLATILIZES
UNDER HEAT OR PRESSURE,
IT WON'T BLOW THE SEAL.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE TOP LABORATORIES
IN THE‐‐IN THE WORLD THAT HAVE
WORKED ON THIS PROJECT.
WHERE ARE YOU SELLING IT?
ALL THE KROGER CHAINS,
RALPHS, 7‐ELEVEN.
UM, WE'RE IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH THEM.
WHY ARE WE EVEN
IN THE WINE BUSINESS?
WHY AREN'T WE LICENSING THIS
TO ALL THE WINERIES?
WHY AREN'T WE GOING TO MONDAVI
AND EVERYBODY ELSE AND SAYING,
"BUY THIS"?
WE ARE. BUT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE WORKING ON PROJECTS
WITH TWO OF THE NINE LARGEST
WINE COMPANIES IN‐‐IN THE WORLD.
YEAH, HOW MUCH MONEY ARE YOU
GONNA MAKE OFF THOSE DEALS?
ESTIMATES NEXT YEAR IS ABOUT
$3 MILLION TO $5 MILLION.
OF SALES?
OF SALES.
NOW I HAVE
A DIFFERENT QUESTION.
WHY DO WE EVEN NEED TO BE IN
THE PACKAGING BUSINESS AT ALL?
MM‐HMM.
WHY IS THIS NOT A PATENT ASSET
THAT WE GO AND MARKET TO
THE LARGEST PACKAGING COMPANIES
ON EARTH?
YOU KNOW, THE WINE INDUSTRY
RIGHT NOW NEEDS COMPANIES
LIKE MINE TO SERVICE THEM
FOR THESE NICHE NEEDS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO INVEST INTO
EQUIPMENT AND HAVE TO LEARN‐‐
ESPECIALLY THIS PROCESS.
THIS IS AN ART. THIS IS NOT‐‐
THIS IS A PROOF OF CONCEPT
IS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
THEY WANT TO KNOW IT WORKS,
'CAUSE THEY'VE SEEN IT
FAIL SO MANY TIMES.
OH, ABSOLUTELY. YEAH.
SO THIS IS HIS WAY
OF SHOWING THAT IT WORKS.
LISTEN, THERE'S A BELIEF‐‐
PIONEERS GET SLAUGHTERED,
AND SETTLERS PROSPER.
WITH THAT SAID, YOU'RE JUST
TOO EARLY FOR ME. I'M OUT.
JAMES, IS THERE A WAY
TO TAKE THE PATENT
OUT OF
COPA DI VINA‐‐DI VINO?
MM‐HMM.
I REALLY LIKE YOUR PATENT.
CAN WE PULL THE TWO APART?
CAN WE SEPARATE
THE LICENSING, I. P.‐‐
FOR CLARITY, I. P.‐‐
THE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
I.P. AS A SEPARATE ENTITY
AND LEAVE YOU
WITH THE WINE BUSINESS?
WE CAN.
SO IF YOU CAN COME BACK
TO ME AND SAY,
"MARK, HERE'S HOW I'D VALUE
THE PATENT,
"THE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY,
HERE'S HOW MUCH CASH I'D LIKE,
AND HERE'S HOW MUCH STOCK
I'M WILLING TO OFFER"...
MM‐HMM.
I'M WIDE OPEN TO THAT.
YEP.
AND THEN YOU CAN OWN AND RUN
WITH YOUR WINE COMPANY...
MM‐HMM.
AND BUILD AS BIG A BRAND
AS YOU LIKE.
MARK, YOU‐‐YOU HAVE‐‐
YOUR ATTENDANCE IN YOUR STADIUMS
EVERY YEAR IS RISING.
OH, NO. IT'S NOT LOST TO ME
THAT I COULD RESELL THESE.
ABSOLUTELY.
NOT LOST TO ME THAT
I COULD STILL BE A CUSTOMER.
I MEAN,
IF YOU MADE A FEW CALLS,
HOW MANY STADIUMS WOULD
THIS PRODUCT BE SOLD IN?
I'M NOT QUESTIONING THAT
AT ALL...
ABSOLUTELY.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO BE IN
THE COMMISSION SALES BUSINESS.
YEAH.
LET'S GET FOCUSED ON THAT, SO
THAT AT LEAST I CAN UNDERSTAND,
IF I GAVE YOU A CHECK
FOR $600,000,
HOW MUCH OF THE I. P. COMPANY
AND BOTTLER I COULD OWN.
HOW MUCH IS THAT?
HOW MUCH ARE YOU WILLING
TO SELL ME FOR $600,000?
20%.
NOT ENOUGH.
YOU'VE ALREADY DEVALUED
THE BRAND TO WORTH THIS MUCH...
(Daymond)
THEY DIDN'T DEVALUE IT.
NO, NO, NO. WE DIDN'T DEVALUE
IT TO ZERO. NOT AT ALL.
(Daymond) THEY JUST SAID
THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED IN IT.
OR A NEGATIVE.
NO, NO. IT'S JUST THAT WE DON'T
WANT TO BE IN THAT BUSINESS.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY SAID
IT'S NOT WORTH ANYTHING. WE‐‐
YEAH. YEAH.
BUT I THINK FOR ME, I'M NOT
GONNA TRY TO TALK YOU INTO
SPLITTING ONE FROM THE OTHER,
AND MY GUT FEEL IS,
IT'S NOT THE DIRECTION
YOU WANT TO DO TODAY.
I'M NOT A WINE GUY. I DON'T
WANT TO BUILD THE BRAND,
SO I'M OUT FOR THAT REASON.
JAMES, I DON'T THINK
I CAN BRING ANYTHING
TO THE TABLE IN THIS.
I'M OUT.
THE REAL VALUE IN
ALL OF THIS IS THE I. P...
UH‐HUH.
BECAUSE IF YOU REALLY OWN IT,
THIS CATEGORY COULD EXPLODE,
AND YOU WILL MAKE SOMETHING OFF
EVERY TIME SOMEBODY RIPS
THE TOP OFF ONE
OF THESE PLASTIC OR GLASS‐‐
SURE. YEP.
THAT'S A BUSINESS, MY FRIEND.
THAT'S HOW YOU GET RICH.
ABSOLUTELY. YEP.
NOW CAN YOU FOCUS ON THAT
AND TELL ME HOW MUCH OF THAT
YOU'D SELL ME FOR $600,000?
♪♪♪
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEVIN ISN'T INTERESTED
IN THE BRAND COPA DI VINO,
BUT HE IS INTERESTED IN
THE PATENT FOR THE PACKAGING.
CAN YOU FOCUS ON THAT
AND TELL ME HOW MUCH OF THAT
YOU'D SELL ME FOR $600,000?
THE REALITY
OF WHAT YOU'RE ASKING IS,
SOME OF
THE COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGES
THAT I HAVE AS A BRAND
AND AS A BOTTLER,
I'M GONNA BE OFFERING AND GIVING
AWAY TO ANOTHER ENTITY,
AND CURRENTLY I'M NOT READY
TO DO THAT.
I FEEL A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
BEING LOST HERE.
I UNDERSTAND BUSINESS.
I UNDERSTAND NUMBERS.
I'VE RUN THE NUMBERS.
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY I'LL MAKE
ON THE I. P. SIDE IS FAR SMALLER
THAN THE GREAT AMOUNT
OF MONEY
THAT I'LL MAKE
ON THE BOTTLING SIDE.
OKAY.
REALLY?
ABSOLUTELY.
ISOLATE THE I. P., ALL RIGHT?
YEP.
I'LL BUY 51% OF IT FOR $600,000.
I'LL TAKE CONTROL OF THAT,
AND I'LL TAKE MY CHANCES
IN TERMS OF LICENSING THIS
TO EVERYBODY IN THE INDUSTRY.
I'LL WORRY ABOUT YOUR DARKEST
FEAR OF NOT MAKING ANY MONEY.
I'LL STILL SLEEP AT NIGHT.
DON'T WORRY.
MM‐HMM.
AND THEN YOU CAN RUN THE BRAND,
YOU CAN RUN THE BOTTLING,
BUT I WILL LICENSE THIS TO THEM.
BUT EVERY TIME THAT HAPPENS,
YOU'LL BE GETTING 49% OF
WHAT I BRING HOME EVERY MONTH.
SURE. THE OPPORTUNITY IS
GREATER THAN THAT.
THE OPPORTUNITY IS
FAR GREATER THAN THAT.
HIS DEAL IS FAR BETTER
THAN WHAT I WOULD OFFER.
REASON BEING, YOU CAN TAKE
THE $600,000 AND USE IT
AS YOU PLEASE AND ACCOMPLISH
EVERYTHING YOU WANTED
TO ACCOMPLISH ON THE OTHER END
AND INVEST IN THAT...
MM‐HMM.
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO INVEST
AND GET ALL THE UPSIDE.
MM‐HMM.
I WOULD NEVER DO A DEAL
LIKE THAT,
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
I‐I HONESTLY THINK
THAT IF I COULD EXPLAIN
TO YOU GUYS A LITTLE CLEARER‐‐
DON'T.
YOU'RE HURTING YOURSELF.
(Daymond)
DON'T SAY ANY MORE.
(O'Leary) NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO. JAMES, JAMES, JAMES‐‐
STOP SELLING, JAMES.
YOU GOTTA STOP SELLING.
I'M A DREAM COME TRUE
FOR YOU.
DO I BELIEVE THIS HAS
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY? ABSOLUTELY.
HAVE I PUT
OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
OF MY OWN MONEY INTO THIS?
I HAVE.
AND IS THAT WORTH GOING AHEAD
AND SELLING, AT THIS POINT
WHAT WE'VE‐‐WHAT WE'VE CREATED,
OFF TO SOMEBODY ELSE
TO CONTROL THAT PORTION OF IT?
THAT'S THE SPECIAL SAUCE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
WHY GIVE AWAY YOUR SPECIAL SAUCE
WHEN YOU CAN HAVE IT INTEGRATED
INTO THE OTHER ASPECTS
OF YOUR BUSINESS
THAT RIGHT NOW
ARE SUCCESSFUL?
I'M WORKING ON‐‐ON‐‐ON,
RIGHT NOW,
CONTRACTS OF OVER
$15 MILLION TO $20 MILLION
ON PRIVATE LABEL PROJECTS
WITH 7‐ELEVEN, WITH TARGET,
WITH SOME OF THE BIGGEST
WINE COMPANIES IN THE WORLD.
WILL HE GET AN ANSWER
AT ANY POINT?
(O'Leary) LOOK, JAMES‐‐
THE ANSWER IS NO.
WELL, THEN COUNTER ME.
WHAT DO YOU WANT FOR 51%?
$3 MILLION.
FORGET IT. NOT A CHANCE.
JAMES, LISTEN TO ME,
I AM GOING TO GO BUY
A THOUSAND‐DOLLAR BOTTLE
OF WINE TONIGHT,
AND I'M GONNA DRINK IT,
BECAUSE I'M WEEPING FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY YOU LOST.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY I CAN
FEEL BETTER ABOUT IT,
AND THEN I'LL NEVER REMEMBER
IT AGAIN, AND I WON'T CARE,
BECAUSE THERE'S
A MILLION OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE GONNA COME TO ME
TOMORROW. THIS WAS YOUR MOMENT.
MM‐HMM.
YOU TURNED AROUND. IT'S GONE.
YOU LOOKED A GIFT HORSE
IN THE MOUTH, JAMES.
OHH.
YOU REALLY DID.
CHEERS.
(Daymond and Robert)
THANK YOU, GUYS.
THE GUY NEEDED ME TO GET FOCUSED
ON WHAT REALLY MATTERED.
YOU COULD'VE‐‐LOOK, YOU COULD'VE
MADE MONEY ON THAT SIDE OF IT,
BUT HE HAD A GRAND SLAM,
AND HE DIDN'T KNOW IT.
I FORGET WHO HE IS.
I DON'T CARE NOW. IT'S OVER.
HE'S A DEAD MAN WALKING,
JUST ANOTHER DEAL.
RIGHT.
KEVIN TOTALLY MISSED THE MARK.
THE VALUE ON OUR PRODUCT
IS THE BRAND.
WE'RE THE FIRST TO DO
WINE BY THE GLASS.
IT'S A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
AND A HUGE MARKET,
AND WE'VE ALREADY PROVED THAT,
SO THE IDEA
THAT WE'RE GONNA BREAK IT DOWN
TO ONE LITTLE COMPONENT,
AND THAT IS SELL THE PATENTS,
WOULD BE SELLING THE LIFE
OUT OF THE OPPORTUNITY.